I like getting cupcakes what's
embarrassing about a cupcake I don't cuz
I just feel like I'm the word cake guy
you know and I can't be what my boys but
girl you got what you guys want to do
their beers strippers I'm like what
about cupcakes anybody it's the way you
say cupcakes
you a cupcake guy you hell yeah bro
absolutely ah for the cupcake go dig in
or you go you go red rag rags what's up
everybody welcome to stupid questions
we're in Los Angeles so we got Justin
Long
that's why you got me I like your energy
so far you have very good vibes oh yeah
absolutely
thanks I really believe that this is a
stupid question what do you think is
something everybody looks stupid doing
selfies dumb a few occasions you know
I've done it I always feel like I'm like
masturbating I always yeah kind of like
yeah I'm embarrassed by and you know I
think everyone looks stupid doing that
and I know we have to but the flight
attendant who has to demonstrate the
safety rules yes yes such an idiot what
would you prefer that a flight attendant
commit to the whole thing like yeah this
way in a very severe like yeah or if
they sometimes they try them funny with
it yet which would you prefer I always
want commitment it's when you try to be
funny that's like stupid I want you to
commit I want you to blow up the
inflatable raft why don't you open up
this door and show me how to slide
that's a serious step but you don't need
to do this here's it
flight attendant that guy has full-blown
FAA flight it's in the face
you have to pick one boat shoes or
khakis boat shoes or khaki pants khaki
pants or boat shoes no choose are the
ones with no laces you know about use
are you from Connecticut am i naked
without naked yeah can you make it with
boat shoes showing if you're Connecticut
piece huh or your with khakis showing
off your man feet well I don't want to
walk around with my stuff outside say
why not do it be proud of it you're from
Connecticut Connecticut I guess that is
a kinetic thing you're right people
couldn't really love to show off their
penis why not dude so yeah it's a
beautiful white dick
yeah I'm gonna say yeah boat shoes now
what I wanted the great people America
to envision just along just boat shoes
and that's what we got and now my mom is
probably happy and warning
congratulations would you rather be able
to only whisper or only shout I'm
talking about a word it's a whisper yeah
that is a really good question well I
feel like la is more of a whisper City
New York's more of a shout City here's
why I think I get wrong because there's
a lot of shouting in cars and driving
you know all of that in but also another
thing I noticed in LA I notice people
being way too demonstrative and
exuberant when they see one another yeah
everything in mono yeah like I asked
somebody that I saw embraced this way
right big hugs I mean they screamed from
across the block you know and I said
just out of curiosity like how long has
it been
oh I always have been since I've seen
you they say weak I guess cuz they're in
yeah week a week
first of all I'm being dead serious
right now huge fan you know you know
what the favorite movie the break-up
when you play yeah he's sittin in the
break up number one I also loved you in
waiting but now I'd like to give you a
stupid gift it's a dodge ball uh-huh
because we're in the movie dodge balls a
big movie blockbuster movie people know
you're from and you know you would be
shocked how many times people yell stuff
like know you want to seem like a goat
or you want to see ya which is a weird
thing yell Rangers so I did this movie
called Zack and Miri Make a Porno and
and I had a line in it where I said you
better shut your mouth or me and TSA guy
once said to me no but you better shut
your mouth or I'm gonna get Wow yeah in
what way is that no that's not a modicum
oh great stupid questions thank you for
playing Jeff thanks Chris no seriously
was it was great team he's really fun oh
thank you yeah a little absolutely
plenty of problem yes
you